i know these questions are desolatory
they keep
going from subject to subject it's just
how my notes are but well regardless you
mentioned one time i think it was to
sean carroll that you can use daniel
dennett's way of speaking of intention
that is
i believe it was give as much intention
as you like to a system in order to
explain what's happening and when i say
intention i mean act as if it's willing
to do something and then you also
mention that one one scales down one's
theological projection to smaller
particles like pan psychics might do
then it leads naturally to quantum
indeterminacy and the least action
principle okay so let's start from the
beginning uh the
dan dennett's intentional stance
is the basically the following idea that
the real
answer
to whether due to how much
intentionality but you know he usually
talks about consciousness but but
intentionality cognition intelligence
whatever whatever you're interested in
the real question of how much of that
some particular system has is not to be
found by sort of armchair philosophy
right to just assume and you know people
say this all the time they say things
like well thermostats can't possibly
have any intention or you know
so so this is this is a decision that
somebody had made it has made just by uh
by by fiat basically and and and dan's
point is is very important it's that
it's an empirical question you can't
just you can't just decide and the way
that you discover this is simply this
you take a particular stance and you say
here's my system i think it has this
much intelligence or i think it's
capable of learning or i think it's able
to uh have preferences and you know or i
think it's a goal directed system
whatever whatever
wherever you choose to uh to start on
that continuum
and using that stance
you do empirical experiments to see how
well that stance helps you to understand
what and control whatever you're dealing
with and so the point being that we
can't simply assume that something is a
non-intelligent system because of what
it's how it's made or because of how it
looks you have to actually ask does
what is the optimal way of of looking at
that system so just to give you a simple
a simple analogy if you have a ball on
top of a hill you are pretty well um
you're going to do pretty well using the
newton's laws to ask how it's going to
roll down the hill and if you have
additional theories about the hopes and
dreams of this ball as it rolls down the
hill they're not going to do you much
good right they're not going to give you
any improved ability to uh to to
understand and control what's going to
happen on the other hand if you start
off with a with a with a live mouse at
the top of a hill and you think you're
going to apply newton's laws you're not
going to do very well uh because you're
going to need some other laws and so you
might decide that the system is is
minimally intelligent and see how you do
you might decide that the system is very
intelligent and it has memories of of
what happened when you put it on the
hill last week and it might do something
different
the point is it's an empirical
experiment you can't just decide what
it's going to be you have to uh you have
to choose a a level of abstraction of
some type of
learning agent maybe maybe all maybe
very little maybe quite a lot and see
how you do so so that's uh so that's
that's the intentional stance is that
that everything is to be decided by the
quality of the predictions and the
amount of control you gain by viewing
your system in a particular light right
so so so everything is is in a way
observer dependent and it's dependent on
the on the
experimental context in which you want
to examine the system you know a human
brain is very intelligent in a certain
context it also makes a great
paperweight and if and if that's the the
how you choose to look at it then you
don't need uh to understand to attribute
much intelligence to it if you're
examining the problem space of keeping
down some papers and a wind then then it
doesn't come up
so so that's so that's so that's that
and so my uh where where i intersect
with this is that
i basically point out that
uh this is a really essential
uh this is a really essential way of
looking at things when
traditional phylogenetics
is is not a great guide and this is
meaning that when we are confronted with
novel creatures they might be novel
bioengineered creatures they might be
chimeras they might be uh something that
you find in space somewhere some
exobiological agent they might be
artificial intelligences that we create
whatever it is
when you are confronted with something
that you cannot simply place on the
familiar evolutionary tree of life in on
earth and say oh yeah this thing is uh
closely related to a fish therefore i'm
going to
i'm going to assume it has roughly the
cognition of other fish that i've known
so when you are
cr either creating or reverse
engineering
novel creatures the intentional stance
becomes completely essential because you
can't know a priori what the cognitive
capacities of this thing are going to be
and they might be uh it might behoove
you to really attribute quite a lot of
cognition to it or maybe not at all
depending on um how
how how that does for you in terms of
empirical success so having said that
then the natural question might come up
is there a zero on this scale so if
you've got a scale uh a a continuum of
cognition or of intelligence that that
is a smooth gradient where different
types of systems might might land right
and so the question is is there in fact
a zero and so what i was saying is is
simply this that
if you
uh if if somebody if somebody had said
to me um
what would the absolute minimum
what would you have to have an absolute
minimum in order to be on this scale at
all right so so to be somewhere on the
scale of cognitive creatures what's the
what's the basement right what's what's
the minimal version that you would have
to have i would say probably the minimum
you would have to have two things you
would have to have some ability to do
goal directed behavior so you would have
to have some kind of ability to to
pursue goal states and you would have
you would have to have some kind of uh
internal uh control such that your um
your your behavior and the things you do
are not perfectly described by all the
external influences around you at a
given time
right in other words in other words if
if i can if i can look at all of the
forces impinging on you and know exactly
what's going to happen then you're
probably a marble running down you know
some kind of an incline plane otherwise
otherwise if if you're if you're more
complex than that then i would have to
take into account things that happened
before things that might happen in the
future all kinds of things that are not
immediately what's what's what's there
so so what that boils down to some sort
of internally
uh internally uh initiated action some
some some quote unquote freedom and
that's you know that's a whole other
story to really dig into that but this
idea that that you would be able to
initiate things on your own you're not
just a responding you're not you're not
just a passive responder to forces
around you at that time and so having
said that having said those two things
you realize that already uh particles
already have those two things because
because particles already exhibit
quantum indeterminacy where they do
things that are that are fundamentally
not caused by any of the things around
them right they're com it's it's
completely uh sort of
an indeterminate and they have the
ability to pursue goals in a very
uh sort of
very primitive manner which is which are
these least action principles and so
one of the benefits of people often say
that um that that pan psychism
is it's it's a bad theory because
because it doesn't lead anywhere it
doesn't give you anything and i think
it's certainly there's there's there's a
little bit of truth to that but
there's um
there's also the fact that if you were
to ask the question
uh i think that even if you were to say
that i think even particles should have
some degree of goal directed activity
you might make a prediction
of of something like the least action
principles existing and then you would
be right you would find you know they
that that model actually makes a
prediction that's completely not obvious
it is it isn't obvious that uh that that
when you have a um a beam of light
passing through a bunch of lenses it's
it's not obvious that you can actually
forego the calculations of how the light
will interact at the with the glass at
every point along the way and simply say
you know what i think i think it wants
to get where it's going with the least
amount of uh action right and so and so
you can you can make the correct
prediction of where it's going to go
simply by assuming that the light likes
to get where it's going um
by minimizing and maximizing certain
things and you could predict something
like that if you had this idea that even
at the very bottom there would be some
type of
some type of
goal directed activity so if we ask what
does that look like what does agency and
intelligence look like in the very
minimal the the most minimal version
possible i think what you get is
something like like particles so from
that perspective i suspect there is no
zero on this scale because because even
particles are already on the scale